Nous sommes persuadés que ces enfants n'ont pas besoin de notre aide,
qu'ils « savent tout » sur la technologie.
Quand j'étais enfant,
à un moment, mes parents m'ont laissé aller seul à l'école.
Après des années à me tenir la main et m'accompagner à l'école,
un jour, ils m'ont fait m'asseoir,
m'ont donné les clés de la maison
et ont dit : « Fais-y attention, ne les donne à personne,
suis la route que nous t'avons montrée, sois à la maison à l'heure prévue,
traverse au coin et regarde des deux côtés avant,
peu importe ce qu'il se passe, ne parle pas aux inconnus. »
Je savais tout sur la marche
et pourtant, il y avait un adulte responsable qui s'occupait de moi.
Savoir faire quelque chose est une chose,
être en sécurité en le faisant en est une autre.
Imaginez cette situation :
j'ai 10 ou 11 ans, je me réveille un matin,
mes parents me jettent les clés et disent :
« Seba, tu peux maintenant aller seul à l'école ».
Puis, quand je rentre en retard,
ils disent : « Tu dois être à la maison à l'heure prévue ».
Et deux semaines plus tard,
quand cela est évoqué, ils disent : « Tu sais quoi ?
Tu dois traverser au coin et regarder des deux côtés avant. »
Puis, deux ans après, ils disent :
« Et ne parle pas aux inconnus. »
Cela semble absurde, n'est-ce pas ?
Nous avons le même comportement absurde avec la technologie.
Nous donnons un accès complet aux enfants
et attendons de voir si un jour, tôt ou tard,
ils apprennent à prendre soin d'eux.
Savoir faire quelque chose est une chose,
être en sécurité en le faisant en est une autre.
Dans la même idée, quand je parle à des parents,
ils disent souvent ne pas s'intéresser à la technologie et aux réseaux sociaux.
Je leur demande toujours s'ils s'intéressent à leurs enfants.
En tant qu'adultes, s'intéresser ou non à la technologie
est la même chose que s'intéresser ou non à nos enfants.
Internet fait partie de notre vie.
La technologie nous force à repenser la relation entre adultes et enfants.
L'éducation a toujours été basée sur deux concepts fondamentaux :
l'expérience et le savoir.
Comment enseigner à nos enfants la sécurité en ligne
si nous ne savons pas comment faire ?
De nos jours, nous adultes devons guider nos enfants
à travers ce qui est souvent un territoire inconnu --
un territoire bien plus attrayant pour eux.
Il est impossible de trouver la réponse
sans faire de nouvelles choses -- qui nous mettent mal à l'aise,
auxquelles nous ne sommes pas habitués.
Beaucoup doivent penser que c'est facile pour moi
car je suis relativement jeune.
C'était ainsi.
Auparavant.
Jusqu'à ce que l'année dernière,
je ressente le poids des années sur mes épaules
la première fois que j'ai ouvert Snapchat.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je ne comprenais rien !
Je trouvais cela superflu,
inutile, difficile à comprendre ;
cela ressemblait à un appareil photo !
Il n'y avait pas de menu !
C'était la première fois que j'ai ressenti le fossé
qui existe parfois entre enfants et adultes.
Mais c'était aussi une opportunité de faire ce qu'il fallait,
sortir de ma zone de confort, me forcer.
Je ne pensais pas un jour utiliser Snapchat
mais quand j'ai demandé à ma cousine adolescente
de me montrer comment l'utiliser,
je lui ai aussi demandé pourquoi elle l'utilisait.
Qu'y avait-il de plaisant ?
Nous avons eu une bonne discussion.
Elle m'a montré son Snapchat, elle m'a dit des choses,
nous nous sommes rapprochés, nous avons rigolé.
Aujourd'hui, je l'utilise.
(Rires)
Je ne sais pas si je l'utilise bien
mais le plus important est que je le connais et le comprends.
La clé était de dépasser le choc initial
et faire quelque chose de nouveau.
Quelque chose de nouveau.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons la chance de créer de nouvelles conversations.
Quelle est votre dernière application téléchargée ?
Quel réseau social utilisez-vous pour contacter vos amis ?
Quel type d'informations partagez-vous ?
Des inconnus vous ont-ils déjà abordé ?
Pourrions-nous avoir ces conversations entre enfants et adultes ?
Nous devons tous nous y forcer.
Aujourd'hui, beaucoup d'enfants nous écoutent.
Parfois, quand nous intervenons dans des écoles
ou sur des réseaux sociaux,
les enfants nous demandent, nous disent des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas dites à leurs parents ou professeurs.
Ils nous disent -- ils ne nous connaissent pas.
Ces enfants doivent connaître
les risques qu'il y a à être seuls en ligne,
comment prendre soin d'eux
mais aussi que, fondamentalement, comme presque tout le reste,
les enfants peuvent apprendre des adultes.
La sécurité en ligne doit être un sujet de conversation
dans chaque maison et chaque classe du pays.
Un sondage cette année a montré que 15% des écoles ont dit
avoir connaissance de cas de grooming dans leur école.
Ce chiffre est en augmentation.
La technologie a changé tous les aspects de notre vie,
y compris les risques auxquels nous faisons face
et comment nous prenons soin des autres.
Le grooming nous le montre de la façon la plus douloureuse qu'il soit :
en impliquant nos enfants.
Allons-nous faire quelque chose pour empêcher cela ?
La solution démarre avec une chose aussi simple
que d'en parler.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)